で 最後の章に入ります
と 今日のテーマであります
善行為はステップバイステップで
怠け者は一発逆転を狙って負ける
だから一発逆転っていうのは怠け者の負け方なんです
地道に努力するんです
ナーンビッカーウェーアーディケーネーバアンニャーラアンニャーラーダナンワガーミアビチャビッカーウェーアヌプッバシッカアヌプッバキリアアヌプッバパティパダーアンニャーラーダナホーティ
一発で解脱に達するとは言いません
達することはできるなんですね
正しい訳訳すれば 一発で解脱に達することはできると言いません
しかし 順番通りに学び
順番通りに実践 順番通りの道で解脱に達するのです
これはキータギリ教なんですね
中部経典 これかなり有名な経典で
内容はかなり大変深いんです
その経典の最後の結論として
ザーッと語ってから結論として出す文章なんです
一発逆転で悟りに達するということはないんだと
順番通りに学んで実践して
道を歩んで いわゆる瞑想して悟りに達するんですよ
この順番とは何やと カタンチャビッカーウェーアヌプッバシッカアヌプッバキリアアヌプッバパティパダーアンニャーラーダナホーティ
順番通りの学び 実践 道とは何ですか？イダビッカーウェーサンダージャーとウパサンカマティウパサンカマントパイルパーセ
師匠に対して信 信頼が起きた人は
その師匠を訪ねる 訪ねてからよく付き合う
付き合う ステップ第一
あのえ？付き合う 仲良くする
あの先生は素晴らしいとよく調べて
信頼が生まれてくる 信頼が生まれたら
その先生を訪ねて その人と仲良くしてください
これは第一のステップなんです
いきなり信じる 信じなさいはないんです
ただ調べて あ 信頼できる人だとわかったら
まあ付き合ってみようか
仲良くしてみる パイルパーさんとソータンオーダハティオーヒテソウトダンマンスナーティ
仲良くすると耳を傾け
耳を傾く気持ちになる
仲良くすると耳を傾いて
こう真理を聞く それで師匠が言うことは信頼できるし
まあ仲良くするって ですから
言うことをね 耳を傾けて話を聞く
いわゆる真理を聞く スットアダンマンダーレーティ
だから説法を聞くことが次のステップなんですよ
第1ステップはまず付き合いなさい
それから話を聞きなさい
いきなり説教を聞くんじゃないんです
で スットアダンマンダーレーティ
ダターナンダンマーナアッタンウパパリッケティ
聞いた教えを覚えておく
これからですね 皆さんが失敗するのは
で 聞いただけではダメなんです
覚えとかないと 覚えた教えの意義を吟味する
ここから聞く気持ちになくなっちゃったんでしょうね
今までのステップは不明なんですけどね
で まあやっぱり次のステップはやっぱり話を聞いて
それからそれは覚えておいて
次のステップはあれって何の意味でしょうかとよく考えてが吟味すると
次のステップはアッタンウパパリッケトダンマーニッジャーナンカマン
吟味をすると 教えに対して納得する
このいまだかつて世の中にない教えだから
よく吟味したところで
あ なるほど その通りだ
世間が言っていることは間違っているんだとはっきりと自分でわかってしまうんです
それは納得ということなんです
そのステップ ステップいくつ言ったんですかね
ダンマニッジャーナカンティアサティチャンドーダーティ
真理に納得をしたところで意欲が生じる
いうことにやる気が出ているものです
あ これは本当のことだとわかったら
もうやる気が出ている
ちゃんとじゃあとじゃあとうっさって意欲が生じたら運ぶんです
やってみるんです うっさいとは取れて
取れてとは これ大事なポイントを覚えておいてください
励んでは比較してみる
比較してはさらに精進する
だからこれ科学実験と同じだからね
やってみて ちょっとちょっとやってみて
どうかな じゃあじゃあこういうことになった
じゃあもうちょっとやってみて
じゃあどうかな？とかね
そういう風に修行はやりながらちょっと測ってみる
このトレーディングっていうのは
この天秤みたいに合わせてみることなんですね
比較というのは 過去の自分と比較するんです
勘違いしないでください
瞑想を強化するんじゃなくて
ちょっと実践してみて
私は昔と今はどんなものかと比較すると差が見えてくるんです
そうすると ちょっとまた修行してみて
今はどうですか？もっと修行して
今はどうですか？そうやって比較
過去と自分と測ってみながら道を進んでいるんです
測ってみないとやる気がなくなっちゃうんですよ
修行は厳しくて 何の結果もないのではないかなと勘違いする可能性があります
結果あるんです 結果見えるのは過去の自分と測ってみる時なんです
過去の自分と今の自分を天秤にかけてみるんです
変わってないかと その時は明らかに変わっていると見えてますので
良い方向です 解脱に達する
パギタットサマーノカーエーナチーガパラマンサッチャンサッチカロディパンニャーチャナンパティヴィッジャパッセティ
精進すると 自分自身で最初たる真理を経験する
一番優れている真理は解脱を経験するのです
この天秤にかけては修行する
天秤にかけては修行する
そうやっている途中でちゃんと悟りに達します
知恵によっても真理を知り尽くす
智慧というものが現れてきて
いわゆるすごい特別な能力
それでものすごく物事は明確に知って落ち着くのです
はい 次のポイント あの信頼さえなければ何も起こらないのです
あの信頼という これは宗教と比較すると
宗教は信仰っていうのを大事にするでしょう
仏教はこの信頼ということを大事に
信仰は神を信仰するのです
信頼はブッダを信仰するんです
いわゆるよく知っている人を信頼するのです
理性があると結果は早い
この一発逆転はないんだけど
人に理性さえあればものすごい結果が早い
アッティビッカーウェーチャトゥッパダヴェーヤーカラナ
ヤッスディッタッサウィンヨ
プリソナチラッセーはパンニャーやったん
あーじゃあねえよ たった四行の教えであっても
それを聞く理性のある人は
間もないうちに真理に達することはあります
ブッダが教えたのはすごい教えですよ
たった四行で十分です
たった一芸で十分です
すべて語っているんです
だから経でもちょっと一行二行の説明ですよ
だからたった四行でも理解して吟味して頑張っちゃえば
ものすごく早く 大量の経典学ぶ時は何年もかかるでしょう
四行だったらもう一日で終わりでしょう
だから理性さえあれば早く達観に達します
しかし これも一発でできるではありません
それだけはないんです
ものすごい早いだけ 師匠を信じられるというポイント
この経典でお釈迦様がすごく強調するのは
この師匠を信じられるんですかと
見てください これは 2600年ぐらい前の話なんです
その時も宗教で人を騙されること
詐欺師たちに散々くたくた人をいじめられて搾取されることというのは
お釈迦様当時でもはっきり言ってるのです
だからこの信頼ということは大きなポイントで
そこからすべて始まります
地獄の道か解脱の道かと
だから人を信頼する場合は徹底的に注意しなくちゃいけないのです
特に人間の場合はもう矛盾の塊だから
決して言うことは信頼できません
だから まあある面で人を信じる流れと頼るなければと言いつつも
ブッダがやっぱりそれにしても先生を師匠を信じ信頼しないと進めないんだと
だからこの問題どうしましょうかといってブッダが語るんだから
ブッダが自分が信頼に値するんだと言ったところで
あらゆる方法で言うんです
信頼するならば 無条件で信頼するならば
釈尊を狙いを信頼しなさい
友達が欲しいと思うならば
戦友といえばブッダのことだ
戦友 戦友と付き合いなさいと言ってますけど
戦友はいません いませんよ
みんなもう矛盾ばっかりだから
建前と本音は違いますから
困るでしょう 困ります
だったらブッダを信じなさいと
ブッダが戦友だよと 私はあなた方の戦友友人であると
あらゆることでブッダの教えを信頼することをできるだけ頑張ってみてあげて
なぜならば そこでこの順番が始まるんだからね
意訳これから直訳は時間がないんだだから意訳できます
俗世間的な利益だけを狙って開祖になる人もいる
世の中で開祖様たちが結構いますけど
みんな俗世間的な利益を狙っているんです
でっかい建物を作って
王様の気取りで生活することを狙っているんです
その人の弟子でさえ これこれやれば私たちにもこれこれの利益
利益があるでしょうと思うんだよ
日本でもいっぱいいろいろ宗教あるでしょうに
明らかに御利益主義でしょう
だからカリスマ様だけはとってもとんでもないご利益を得ていますけど
信者さんもまあなんとかご利益あるでしょうということで
商売繁盛するでしょうとか
子供の病気が治るでしょうとかね
それぐらいつまらないご利益を考えて
その宗教を信頼しているでしょう
しかし 釈尊は微塵も利益を求めない
利益に微塵も染めない
お釈迦様は微塵も期待していないのです
だから純粋にきれいさっぱり献身的にしてあげるだけ
何にもしてもらいたいということがまるっきりない
褒めてもらいたい 拝んでもらいたい
認めてもらいたい まるっきりない
はっきり言うんです これ嘘だと
俗世間の利益は利益は
あるお釈迦様が悟り達する前に夢を見たという話があります
お釈迦様が言うんだから
お釈迦様の 説法していると思いますけど
でもそれは悟りの前に見た夢として語られているんです
夢 5つなんですけど 一つの夢はもう墨染のごとく墨染って見たことないでしょ
まあまあ富士山にしましょう
富士山のごとくでっかいクソの山がある
こんなすごいクソ山がある
釈尊がその上歩いてるんだと
しかし 微塵も足が汚れない
その夢の解説は何なのかというと
自分が解脱に達することは確かですと
一旦解脱に達したら 世の中の初めてのことだから
人々はあらゆるお布施を持ってきてもう付するでしょうと
しかし ブッダたる者は何にもとらわれることなく
クソの上に歩いているような感じで
気持ち悪いと思う 触れて欲しくないんです
その夢で そのたとえで言っているのは
どれほどお釈迦様が世間の利益に対して嫌悪感を持っていたかという
嫌悪感と言わない本離観ですね
その場合は関係ない 離れてるような
だから信頼できるでしょう
仏陀の 何かとらわれる捉えるとかありえないんです
だから完全に悟っているんだから
完全に煩悩がなくなっているんだから
もう解脱に入るんだから
涅槃に入るんだから もういらん何も
あえてブッダにとっては人間ってに関わることはすごい迷惑なんです
なのに迷惑もいいところなに？説法する
朝も昼も夜も時々徹夜してですね
それは偉大なる憐れみなんです
心配なんです だからブッダを信頼しなさいよと
この信頼というものができたら
さっと順番で進んでしまいます
ですから この教えに信頼を抱く方が良いのですと
これはブッダの言葉 私は意訳で書いたんです
純粋に憐れみを持って語られるので
仏説は信頼に値する 弟子はこのように思う
だから正しい弟子はこのように思う
サッターバグワーサーコーハマスミジャーナーティバグワーナーハンジャーナーミーティ
世尊は師匠です 私は弟子です
世尊は知っている 私は知らない
それが信頼の言葉なんです
その気持ち 心に正直生まれたら
まあブッダを信頼する人で
もうブッダの仏教の道に入ったものになるんです
ネムノス になるんです
世尊は師匠です 私は弟子です
世尊は知っている 私は知らない
何もということ どんな苦労があっても
結果が出るまで精進努力しなくてはならない
だから弟子はこう思うんです
そんなに手放しそうだから
まだ全て知っているんだから
たとえ苦しくても たとえ体の中の血液が枯れてしまっても
修行だけは捨ててやろうと
結果出るまで で 長い文章なんですけど
努力する人間 勇者たる者がもう戦う
戦士がもう戦うように
やるべきことはちゃんと成し遂げますよというふうに決めておくんですね
大体ここら辺で終わると思います
で 確固たる結果 サッダッスビッケウェーサーカッササトゥサーセネパリオーパリオーガエワッタトーデンナンパラナンアンニャタランパランパハティカンカンディッ
ケーダンメアンニャサティバウパーリセセアナガーミッターミ
信頼を起こし 励む弟子には 2つの結果があります
今世で解脱に達するか
もしも修行を完了できなかったならば
不還果に達するかです
確実にこの結果  2つのひとつになるんだよと
解脱に達するか もうちょっと完了する前に亡くなったら不還果で亡くなります
不還果というのは 悟りの 3番目の段階
もう俗世間に戻らない
そこで悟りに達します
はい これで終わり はい
そういうことで 良いことはゆっくりと順番で行うものであるという話で
一発逆転はないんだと
だからまああんまり余計な欲と夢を抱くとうまくいかない
それは物で考えるんだから
やはり仏教でいう順番というのは
まず信頼する 信頼する前に調べればいいんです
それから仲良くしてみる
そうするとさらに信頼が良くなる
それから話を聞いてみる
それから話を覚えておいて理解して
理解したところで納得がいくし
納得がいったならばやる気が出てくるし
やる気が出たらやればいいんです
やる気もないのにやりなさいとはないんです
だからいつでも人の自由というのは守ってあげてるんです
そういう宗教なの 宗教じゃないんですね
だから結局は はい そういうことで
長い時間になりましたけど
どうもありがとうございます
ありがとうございます